anas with us in washington DC hi Anna
how are you hi Dave I'm doing well thank
you for taking my question um so in 2006
my husband I purchased our first home
and 2008 the market crash and slash the
value of our house now three years ago
our family grew and we bought a new home
with a 20% down it's been 12 years now
and our first home it's still not worth
what we're about it for and wait a
minute wait a minute
that's not economic there's something
else going on a few places in the United
States have not recovered after 12 years
would you buy a brain or what I I don't
understand it either because we live in
Northern Virginia which is like very
close to Washington DC and right now
it's worth 295 kitchen and we bought it
at according to a realtor and we bought
the house at 350 K a recent comparative
market analysis by quality real estate
agent says this house is worth 300 grand
okay is that what you're telling me yes
so you must have done the world's worst
real estate deal I said well like it
like we said like I we bought the house
in 2006 you know what I also got an
innate you owe on it right now we all
about 60 K on it Oh sell it it's quite
we should sell it it's crap it's the
world's worst house here's the thing in
12 years it sucks so you don't think we
should wait for 12 years
all right here that fact eventually my
question because right now we're a baby
and I'm baby step number six here's the
thing I gave you three hundred thousand
dollars in cash would you go buy the
house next door
no why because it sucks this
neighborhood is not appreciating for
some reason or another it's the world's
worst rate of return meanwhile the rest
of the nation gripped way down and is up
20 percent I agree with you is this why
I'm calling it because I'm trying to
decide if we should continue to rent
this out no and wait until okay no it's
a bad investment it's a bad neighborhood
I don't know what's wrong here but I
mean a house you paid three and fifty
thousand dollars for in two thousand
freaking six before the crash it goes
down and it's not even recovered back to
350 it mean that's a very unusual real
estate market unusually bad and I don't
want to invest in it going forward and
so I wouldn't keep it going forward take
your take your loss and get out you
bought in a really bad place for some
reason I don't know what's wrong but
that's the worst numbers I've heard and
I don't know when I mean everywhere else
just about is recovered Florida went
down Phoenix went down freakin Las Vegas
crashed and has recovered you know I
mean but there's some you know there's
some parts of Detroit that haven't but
those are economic pockets it's not an
overall national economy thing and so
you don't buy in bad economic pockets
yeah and you don't keep in bad economic
pockets and so out of there I'm out of
there if I'm you I'm out of there done
quickly done yes thanks for the call
appreciate your joining us sucks hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]